there she is let's let's hear directly
from the Prime Minister nearly three
years have passed since the public voted
to leave the European Union it was the
biggest Democratic exercise in our
country's history I came to office on a
promise to deliver on that verdict in
March 2017 I triggered the article 50
process for the UK to exit the EU and
Parliament supported it overwhelmingly
two years on MPs have been unable to
agree on a way to implement the UK's
withdrawal as a result we will now not
leave on time with the deal on the 29th
of March this delay is a matter of great
personal regret for me and of this I am
absolutely sure you the public have had
enough you're tired of the infighting
you're tired of the political games and
the arcane procedural rouse tired of MPs
talking about nothing else but brexit
when you have real concerns about our
children's schools our National Health
Service knife crime you want this stage
of the brexit process to be over and
done with I agree I am on your side
it is now time for MPS to decide so
today I have written to Donald Tusk the
president of the European Council to
request a short extension of article 50
up to the 30th of June to give MPs the
time to make a final choice do they want
to leave the EU with a deal which
delivers on the result of the referendum